it's a unique tune that hasn't come easy
but Jay Hendrick is ready to get
loud the trans student dropped out of
school last year before graduating tired
of the insults are you a he she or they
or an it you look like an IT comments
Hendrick took to heart Jay currently
does go by it as a pronoun and isn't
alone in its concern we are not happy
with this
students across Alberta gathered in
protest of the province's proposed
lgbtq2 policies we're not going to be
quiet this is our fight and it shouldn't
be but we are the next voting age we're
not happy with this and we're going to
keep fighting until this is changed from
parental consent on changing pronouns to
age limits on top and bottom surgery the
premier says the policies are meant to
protect kids citing long-term Health
impacts for people like Lois Cardinal
who consulted with Danielle Smith on the
proposed policies I was asking for
better after care and preventions
Cardinal social media posts frequently
refer to transgenderism as a mental
disorder at 21 she says she immediately
regretted her bottom surgery and
campaigned for the changes announced
last week I support it and then there's
others within the community that don't
and I understand that but this is the
first steps that we need to take medical
evidence indicates cases involving
regret are exceedingly rare and the
mental health benefits for transgender
youth outweigh the risk people waiting
for these procedures are at very high
risk of having uh Mental Health crisis
and suicidality and when you intervene
when you start hormones or when you are
able to offer potentially other
procedures that that uh crisis point for
people drops way down HRI lost a trans
friend to Suicide just a few months ago
those long-term Health implications are
being alive still and not killing
yourself and worries other trans youths
are losing their ability to find their
own Rhythm Sarah ofen Global News